hey youtubers is Charlie so Game of
Thrones Season six has already started
casting some characters and a lot of
people think that you're on Greyjoy
might be one of them so I'm gonna read
this casting description and then
explain him a little bit so the casting
description reads a male pirate in his
40s to late 50s who has terrorized the
seas all around the world cunning
ruthless with a touch of madness he's a
dangerous looking man so right away this
screams euron greyjoy one of Theon
huncles he's a really big character in
the books but he hasn't really shown up
till books four and five so far that's
why we haven't seen him on the show
there's another uncle called Victarion
who kind of gets tied up with Joran
story until now it just seemed like the
show was gonna completely cut out the
rest of the Ironborn storyline which
everyone got really upset about because
they're a really big group in the books
that they play a really big part in the
war of Ice and Fire
it's just that anytime the show cuts
characters out like young Griff it just
it makes people feel like they're dead
ends in the books that isn't the case I
mean you know young Griff plays a really
big part in the books it's just the show
tries to be a little more economic and
the scope of the narrative that's what
happens when you only get ten episodes
of season it's not confirmed that you're
on is the characters that are casting
it's still a fan theory you know
based on that description in the way
that they cast characters for the show
that is the best theory so far usually
what happens is is when they first start
casting characters like you know right
around this time of the year they cast
the really big ones first the ones that
they announced at Comic Con every year
and then they pick up some of the lesser
ones along the way the latest I remember
them casting someone in season four was
the child of the force that we saw in
the season four finale they didn't
announce that till like November of 2013
I think so even though they start
shooting really early they still cast
people throughout the years they need
them in episodes it's just you know the
bigger characters they need in more
episode so they have to cast them sooner
so regardless of who these like really
big people that they're just starting to
cast right now are will probably get to
meet them at Comic Con last year they
announced the sand snakes Duran Martell
Aereo and the high Sparrow is really
like the only new material that the show
ever brings to Comic Con like they they
don't bring trailers for the new season
in all fairness to the producers though
the reason they don't bring footage is
because they haven't started shooting
the new season yet so there's nothing to
show but just to do a quick rundown of
your own in the books he's Theon's
oldest uncle
Theon's father Balon Greyjoy's older
brother he's described as being handsome
but he's only got one eye and he drinks
this blue drink every night that gives
his lips this constant bluish cast he
claims to have at one time had a dragon
egg that he said he threw overboard in
one of his moods it sounds like he got
really frustrated and in drunk one night
and just decided to chuck it overboard
because he couldn't figure out how to
hatch it he claims to have sailed all
the way to a sigh which is actually
where mellow Sanders from it's on the
other side of the Eastern continent so
it's actually really really far away he
even claims to have walked through the
ruins of ancient Valyria that that's the
place where Tyrion and Jorah went a
couple episodes ago in the time line you
know right around when season 1 is
picking up he's been banished from the
Iron Islands for raping his brother
Victarion salt wife if that doesn't seem
bad enough you know salt salt wives you
have to remember or women that the
Ironborn captured during raids and
turned into bound concubines so oh you
know already we're on like shaky ground
here he raped his brothers concubine who
his brother himself had captured and had
been raping but as nuts as that all
sounds like they still have a code that
they live by they're not allowed to kill
kin so his recompense Euron was banished
so in the time that the show has been
going on like as a story's been moving
along he's just been out sailing around
maybe he knows where Gendry is who knows
Vik Tyrion in the in the context of the
story is the commander of the iron fleet
he stayed pretty close to the sea stone
chair so he commands Balon Greyjoy's
forces in the board of the five kings
the show thus far has given most of that
story line to Theon's sister
so it's possible if the shows going with
Joran they'll just completely cut out
Vic Tyrion they'll give like all of
Victarion story to your on the reason
everyone thinks it's gonna be you're on
in knock-back Tyrion is because george
RR martin describes the Victarion as a
dullard and a prude and duller just
doesn't scream cunning as is described
in this pirate casting call he's still
pretty interesting character like he
wears full plate mail and he associates
with a priest of the red God who's a
character that the show might do so I'm
gonna save him for later just just in
case they do cast the character the cool
thing about the Ironborn is is that it
also kind of brings in some more context
for the priests of the red God so you
know hopefully in season six we will get
to see the inside of a red temple or at
least get to learn more about the faith
of the red God most of the show thus far
has been spent in Westeros the dominant
religion there is the faith
seven Melisandre and Thoros Amir were
actually sent to Westeros to try and get
like a foothold for the faith of the red
God to try to try and spread that
religion
that's why Melisandre was so
disappointed in Thoreau's whenever she
met him he'd been sent to King's Landing
and utterly failed in his mission in
addition to Iran and Victoria and though
Balon actually has two other brothers we
might see one of the other ones just
going in order
Euron is the oldest then there's Vic
Tyrion then uragan who actually died as
a child so we're never gonna see him
then there's air on the damp hair there
is a scene in season 2 where Theon gets
baptized by someone that looks like
Aaron but he wasn't called Aaron in the
script so he could be just some random
character the reason you should be
excited about your uncle a joy though is
that because of all Theon's family he is
the most fun character most of the
personalities and Theon's family flow
from Balon Greyjoy you know there are a
lot of variations they're all very
different characters
Joran himself is said to have always
followed the old ways they judge you
based on your ability as a Raider like
the only jewelry they wear around our
ornaments that they win in battle or
spoils of war like trophies that they
wear around I think one of the reasons
why people like the Ironborn so much is
just because they are so open about
their lifestyle their default mode is to
take what they want like raiding and
being pirates are historically their
main industry that changed a little in
recent years like they still are even
rape you know taking whatever they want
but not nearly as much as they used to
Balon Greyjoy was suppressed after the
Greyjoy rebellion that that's like in
the events leading up to season 1 so
they were much quieter in recent years
obviously the War of the five kings
changed that though Balon Greyjoy
declares himself king of the Iron
Islands and you know they start making
war on the East Coast the circumstances
of Euron's return or you know his
arrival in the story in person are kind
of spoilery so I'm not going to talk
about those now if you do every if you
have read the books please use spoiler
tags on the show he's supposed to be in
his 40s or 50s in the books you're on is
only in his 30s but you remember that
everyone on the show is kind of aged up
about 10 years like Jaime and Cersei are
about 10 years older they're in their
40s instead of their 30s Tommen is
probably the best example that in the
books he's only about 9 years old
obviously they're not gonna make Natalie
Dormer have sex a little kid so you get
the idea most of the Ironborn we've seen
on the show so far are fairly
practical people you know like they have
their own religion they worship the
drowned God we've seen bits of that
you're on though you know as is
described has a touch of madness
so his ambitions are much much grander
and we're kinda at that time in the in
the story whereby things are reaching a
crescendo so you expect crazier and
crazier characters to come on that's one
of the challenges of the show is that is
we approach like the final season is
that the spectacles have to get bigger
and bigger and bigger
Euron is a character that fits really
well with that metaphor but like I said
that you know they make cats the
announcements for 11 other characters so
there's a lot of other people that we
can talk about I'll probably wait till
after the season to do them there's
still a lot of things left that could
happen so you know after the finale
it'll be a little bit easier to make
predictions about which characters look
bringing on here's my big question for
you guys though do you think that the
show is bringing on your and Greyjoy and
if they do do you think that they'll
just you know combine a couple other
Ironborn characters and give that story
to him as much as the show cuts out they
still try to do relatively big
storylines but you know sometimes they
have to swap characters based on people
that they've killed off or people that
they cut out entirely
speaking of which George are Martin
actually just announced that he's not
going to be writing any scripts for
season six some people are freaked out
by this but I actually think it's a good
thing because he said it would take a
month away from writing winds of winter
he just said that it takes him about
three weeks to write a script and then
like a week after that to get back into
book mode so you know what would you
rather have like a george RR martin
episode or winds of winter the best
theory right now is that you know based
on the pace of his writing he'll finish
somewhere around the beginning of season
six you know or at least by the end of
season six so as much as the show is
passing the books in the timeline they
will kind of even up you know around
season six it's not gonna be perfect but
if you're a book purist you will have
that material to read Dory when that
actually when that does drop I will give
away a bunch of copies the people that
actually want books this year that one
the signed copies that I that I sent out
should be receiving them pretty soon the
other really cool thing about that too
is later this year george RR martin is
reira leasing the dunk and egg stories
like he's just combining them all in a
single book called a night of the seven
kingdoms that's coming in October so
I'll give away copies whenever that
happens until then like the weekly
giveaways like right now will still be
the HBO now subscription but I'll
probably do an extra special giveaway
for the finale my episode 8 video
tonight will post right after the
episode airs so be sure to subscribe to
get that that that's when the new round
of the
start if there are any bonus videos that
you guys really want for next week just
be sure to leave me requests in the
comments so why use wait for that to
post you can click here for last week's
episode and you can click here to learn
all about maester aemon thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight